[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال الاختيار السهلوها
بابره العمل
خلاف غربي حول دعم كيف بالطائرات بارزلات
مانع وبريطانيا ترفضه في الوقت الحالي
ين
ويجدد دعوته لحل الدولتين
[تصفيق]
سمعه النظام اعتقال مرجع ديني بارز في
بلوشستان وتاهب لانفجار احتجاجيه وشيك
[تصفيق]
وفي فرنسا مليونان و 800 الف متظاهر
شاركوا باضراب ثان خلال اقل من اسبوعين ضد
قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من الحرب في اوكرانيا
فامكانيه ارسال المقاتلات الكياف اظهرت
خلافا اخر بين الحلفاء الغربيين حول مساله
زعم اوكرانيا خلال حربها ضد روسيا باريز
عادت وجدت عبر وزاره دفاعا انها لا ترى
ارسال الطائرات الحربيه لاوكرانيا امرا
مستحيلا قبلها لم يمانع الرئيس الفرنسي
الامر ذات ولكن على الجهه الاخرى من بحر
المعاش هناك معارضه بريطانيه للامر
استعتبر لندن الامر غير واقعيه حاليا وفقا
يبدو متردده قابلا للتغيير في اي وقت كما
حصل مع ارسال باتريوت ودبابات ابرامز
[موسيقى]
من جانبها
المتحدث تعبير
اما في ملف الدبابات كشف وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ديميتروكوليبا عن عدد الدبابات
التي تلقتها كياب ضمن الدفعه الاولى
والدعم الاول من الدول الغربيه والتي ترى
واحد بين 120 الى 140 دبابه حديثه منها
طبعا ليوباغ وتشالنجر
240 دبابه غربيه حديثه
كما نعول كثيرا على دبابات هذا ليس عددا
صغيرا لكننا نواصل العمل على توسيعه
الدبابات وزياده الدعم من الحلفاء
هذا واجرت القوات الاوكرانيه اول تدريبات
على استخدام دبابات ليوبار الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
رغم ان المانيا رابع واكبر مانح للدفاع
الاوكرانيه الا ان ترددها بشان النقل
دبابات ليوباغ اثنين جعلها موضع شيك
اوروبي لظهورها بموقع المرتبك وغير الراغب
في القياده فالمراوغه المطوله في مسائل
الامن الاوروبي زعزع الثقه عملائها
وشجعتهم على استكشاف خيارات اخرى للاجهزه
الدفاعيه وفي غياب قوه قياديه فرنسا
والمانيا تغيب اي خطوط انتاج دبابات ساخنه
اخرى في اوروبا ما فعل الخطط البديله
والتي تصب طبعا في كوريا الجنوبيه وفقا
لفرنسا حيث فازت شركه في كوريا الجنوبيه
بعقود اسلحه ضخمه مع بولندا العام الماضي
تضمنت صفقات لشراء 1000 دبابه قتال رئيسيه
وهي كي تو وما دافع ذاتيه الدفع الصفقه
الكوريه وفرت البولندا الحصول على دبابات
بوقت اسرع وبسعر تنفسي طبعا كما ناسبت
رغباتها بنقل التكنولوجيا لتعزيز صناعه
الدفاع المحليه الخاصه بها الامر هنا لا
يقتصر على بولندا فقط فدت بابا القتال
الرئيسيه في تركيا مشتقه من التي طراز
كيتو وقد انخرطت دول مثل السلوفاكيا مع
كوريا الجنوبيه لمناقشه خيارات استبدال
دبابات تي 72 قديمه وكذلك النرويج وفنلندا
واستراليا
[موسيقى]
ورشه والاصلاح البولنديه السريه للاسلحه
الاوكرانيه المتعطله توصف بالتحدي الاكبر
في هذه الحرب ففي مصنع بحجم ملعب كره
القدم تحيط به مباني المهجوره يعمل مئات
الفنيين لاصلاح المدفعيه والدروع الثقيله
واعادتها الى خط المواجهه عبر الطريق الذي
شهد اكبر عمليه نقل الاسلحه في اوروبا منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الفنيون داخل
المصنع وعددهم 400 تقريبا يعملون في ثلاث
نبات على مدار الساعه وهم على اتصال
المنتظم بالاوكرانيين في ساحه المعركه فهم
يعلمونهم عبر التطبيقات المشفره افضل
التقنيات للاصلاحات سواء الدبابات او
الصواريخ وكيفيه اكتشاف المشكلات اصلاح كل
سلاح قد يستغرق شهرين تجتاز هذه الاسلحه
فحوصات امنيه قبل السماح لها بالصعود الى
ارضيه المصنع ويراقب الورشه ضبا مسلحون من
جهاز الامن الداخلي مكلفين طبعا بالكشف عن
عمليات تخريب محتمله طالت سابقا مصانع
اسلحه في دول اخرى بينها بلغاريا كما تشمل
قواعد الورشه ان يكون كل فرد من موظفي
التجمع والتجميع والانتاج واي زائر للمبنى
سيكون مواطنا بولنديا ما يعني استغراق اي
عمليه فرز لموظفين جدد بغض النظر عن
الرتبه اشهر عداء تحدي صيامه واصلاح ذخائر
سيزيد تعقيدا مع قرب وصول الدبابات
الغربيه الى ساحه المعارك والمقدر عددها ب
10030 على ان يتم اصلاح دبابات ابرامز في
مدينه بوزنان وفقا ترجيحات وبحسب طبعا
مسؤولين بولنديين الورشه قد تتوسع قريبا
لاصلاح وصيانه المعدات المصنعه في الخارج
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا منك
السابق اهلا بك
قبل
التسريحه الغربي اليوم الكياس برايكم هو
فقط لسد احتياجات الحرب ام انه ابعد من
ذلك من ذلك طبعا لاستنزاف موسكو على حسابك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
والتحيه الطيبه نائمين اوكرانيا
تحاولوا تحقيق الاستنظافه
اوكرانيا واوكرانيا
كل هذه المعادات عسكريه الثقيله منها
الصاعده
[موسيقى]
واحد بصراحه همم نحن سوف نحصل على كل هذه
المعادات عسكريه نحن نحتاج الان لان نحن
نشهد روسيا تهاجم بشكل
مصالح او كريميه كما في جنوب اوكرانيا في
زبريجه كمان في منطقه
وكمان عندي بصراحه اخر حول تصريحات
البايندنج يعني تقديم المقاتلات
الاوكرانيا اف سي اف 16 يوم اوكرانيا همم
امر غير عمليه
بما انك تتحدث عن الالف 16 هناك
الاوكرانيه بان الرفض الاميركي هو غير
نهائي طبعا بالفتره الماضيه كان هناك
سياسه امريكيه وهي التسليح المتدرش هل
يعني تعتبرون ان المرحله المقبله من الحرب
ستتضمن 16
نعم اكيد هذا السياسه كما نحن نشهد كل
شاهر قبل امريكا
الان لان روسيا تحرش بعده كبير
وحاطه في شمال
ومهمه جدا بمناسبه بيان سوف تكون بني
تخطيط للصيانه كل معادلات عسكريه في
بولاندا يعني واحد انه اوكرانيا تحتاج
كمان بانها كل هذه البنيه تحتيه للصيانه
الدفع الروسي والتحضير الروسي لعمليه
الربيع هناك نظره تشاؤميه اليوم بوسائل
الاعلام والصحف الغربيه بان افضل ما يمكن
ان تحققه اكياس حتى مع الدعم مع الدعم
الاسلحه هو طريق كارسي مسدود امام القدرات
الروسيه هناك هل يعني هذه النظره ممكن ان
تفرمل او تزيد الدعم العسكري
كل شيء في جهات امريكا واغارف يعني
واذا اوكرانيا سوف تحصل على كل هذه
المعادلات
عسكريه الثقيله في اقرب وقت وهذا سوف يكون
جيدا ولكن
التماس كما في جنوب اوكرانيا
وكمان كل جابر الوقت
خصوصا انا نتحدث عن دعم باكثر من مئه
مليار دولار يعني عسكري سياسي همم ايضا
يعني مال الثياب منذ بدء هذه العمليه شكرا
لك استاذ فلوديمير شو ماكو اديبلوماسي
السابق حدثنا عبر سكايب
اجرى الجيش الفرنسي استعدادات لتدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه على دبابات ليوباخ
اثنين الالمانيه واكد الجيش البولندي
تجهيز مركز تدريب بالقرب من الحدود
الالمانيه باجهزه محاكاه وكذلك بمدربين
محترفين يمكنهم تدريب
14 طقم من اربعه افراد في وقت واحد واوضح
الجيش الجيش البولندي ان خمسه اسابيع من
التدريبات المكثفه كافيه للتدريب الاطقم
الاكرانيه على دبابات
عندما نتحدث عن تدريب شخص اعتاد العمل على
الدبابات السوفيتيه فانه يحتاج لتدريب
لمده عشره اسابيع على دبابات 2 وابرمز
واذا قمنا بتكثيف التدريبات فسنتمكن من
تدريب الطاقه في غضون خمسه اسابيع
موعد او توقيت وصول الدبابات الغربيه الى
اوكرانيا ونشرها في جبهات القتال العامل
الابرز لاحراز تقدم حيث يتخوف خبراء
عسكريون من عدم وصولها في الوقت المناسب
اي السباق الهجوم الروسيه المتوقع في
فبراير وسطه مجموعه الدبابات التي يحتمل
وصولها اولا هي الدبابات البريطانيه
الاربعه عشره تشالنجر 2 ورجحت صحيفه
نيويورك ان تصل في اواخر مارس على ان تبدا
عمليه التشغيل وايصال هذه الدبابات للخطوط
الاماميه في ايبريل او ما يعلى ابعد تقطيع
دبابات اثنين الالمانيه صنع التي تعهدت
بها المانيا وغيرها من حلفاء اوكرانيا
الاوروبيين قد تصل في نفس الوقت تقريبا
لكن ليس دفعه واحده فالجدول الزمني يعتمد
على سرعه كل حكومه لكن من شبه المؤكد ان
وصول دبابات ابرمز الامريكيه سيستغرق وقتا
اطول ويتمثل بشهور
الى الوضع الميداني حيث اكد الصحيفه
تلغراف تكبد القوات الروسيه خسائر فادحه
خلال هجومها على بلده فهد لتعدين الفحم
جنوب باخمود مضيفه ان الهجوم كان له تكلفه
باهضه ونقلت عن عقيد اوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه يتم سحقها خلال هجومها على مدينه
مدينه
الى انشاء مركز الدفاع قوي للغايه هناك
وغرفه اتصالات في طابق ارضي لكن العقيد
الاوكراني اكد ان سقوط سوليدار وضع عروس
من الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه على مقربه
خطيره من الطريقه السريع بين باخموت وسوف
اما الفين جنوب نجحوا في تطويق المدينه
ويقعون في نطاق الطريق الرئيسيه المؤدي
الى شريان ده ده الرئيسيه الاخر للمنطقه
اكد وزير الخارجيه المجاري ان بلاده تدعم
توسيع مضيفا ان وجهه نظرهم واضحه حول
الانضمام المستقبليه المحتمل للسويد
وفنلندا
حول الانضمام المستقبلي المحتمل للسويد
وفي لندن الى الناتو نحن ندعم توسيع
الناتو وفي فبراير خلال الجلسه الاولى
للجمعيه الوطنيه سيكون التصديق على
الانضمام على جدول الاعمال وبعد ذلك سنكون
قادرين على التفاوض عليه بطريقه سريعه اما
بالنسبه لحذف الحكومه التركيه على القيام
بذلك فانا لاحظ اي حكومه اجنبيه اخرى على
القيام باشياء لا تهمنا
من شان ابن اخر اشاره وزير الخارجيه تركيه
الى ان بلاده تنظر بايجابيه اكثر الى
انضمامي فنلندا لعضويه
على انضمام الدولتين في وقت واحد اذا كان
هناك قرار بطلبات منفصله وننظر فيها بشكل
منفصل فسيكون موقفنا فيما يتعلق بفرلندا
اكثر ايجابيه
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
واشنطن تفرض عقوبات جديده على كيانات
ايرانيه بسبب دعم روسيا بانتاج المسيرات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطونيو صحفي في القدس الغربيه
على اهميه خفض التصعيد واستئناف محادثات
السلام بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
الولايات المتحده عازمه على العمل مع
شركائها لتعزيز بيئه اكثر استقرارا وايجاد
حلول وسطى للحروج من دوامه العنف واستئناف
محادثه السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وطالبنا كافه الاطراف بخفض
التصعيد
وحذر خلال مؤتمر صحفي في القدس الغربيه من
ان الولايات المتحده لن تقبل باي خطوات
احاديه قد تجعل من مساله حل الدولتين امر
اعقد مما هي عليه الان
كله واضحين ومتفقين في قناعتنا بانه لا
ينبغي لاي من الطرفين اتخاذ اي اجراءات
احاديه جانب الان من المحتمل ان تصب الزيت
على النار على مدى فتره طويله من الزمن
الى ابعد مما هو عليه
اليوميه ورقه من اثني عشر بنت تخص
الاجراءات الاحاديه الجانب التي تقوم بها
اسرائيل وقضايا الوضع النهائي وطالبت من
الاداره الامريكيه ان تجبر اسرائيل على
الالتزام بها كشرط لاعاده التنسيق مع
اسرائيل وعوده الهدوء تمهيدا لاي مفاوضات
محتمله عبد الحفيظ جعوان والتفاصيل
توج وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتونوبلنكن
سلسله الزيارات الامريكيه الى رام الله
هذا الشهر بداها مستشار الامن القومي ثم
مديره وكاله الاستخبارات السيائيه المطلب
الامريكي من الفلسطينيين هو التهدئه
والثمن وعد بالحفاظ على مبدا حل الدولتين
واعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس
الشرقيه و 50 مليون دولار الى جانب توفير
خدمه الجيل الرابع للانترنت وغيرها
في هذه الاثناء نحن نعرض اي اجراء من جانب
اي طرف لجعل حل الدولتين صعب المنال ونحن
كنا واضحين ان هذا يشمل اجراءات كتوسيع
المستوطنات وتشريع البؤري الاستيطانيه
واعمال هدم البيوت واخلاء المنازل من
سكانها وتغيير الوضع القائم التاريخي في
الاماكن المقدسه
الوعود والزيارات الامريكيه لرام الله
تبدو مرضيه نوعا مال السلطه الفلسطينيه
بعد قطيعه اداره ترامب لكن ليست كافيه
فيرىى الفلسطينيون ضروره ان تترجم الى
خطوات عمليه على الارض لعوده المسار
التفاوضي لذلك سلموا لاداره الامريكيه
ورقه من 12 بندا ابرزها ان تتوقف اسرائيل
عن اقتحام المدن وتوسيع المستوطنات وتغيير
الوضع التاريخي والديني في القدس
للعمل مع الاداره الامريكيه
والمجتمع الدولي لعوده الحوار السياسيه من
اجل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عمليات من جانب الاداره الامريكيه لتنفيذ
ايلتزام من هذه الالتزامات منزل تسلم هذه
الاداره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طلب من
القياده الفلسطينيه اعاده التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل والحد من انتشار المجموعات
المسلحه وبسط السيطره الامنيه والمضيء
بالاصلاحات القانونيه نتائج زياره بلينكن
للمنطقه ستظهر بعد انتهائها مباشره ان
كانت اسرائيل ستوقف اقتحامات المدن وبناء
المستوطنات وهدم المنازل ام ان وزراء
حكومه نتنياهو من اليمين المتطرف سيواصلون
مغامره تكون نتائجها دمويه كما حدث في
الشهر الاول من هذا العام عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
للحديث اكثر عن هذه الزياره ينضم الينا من
القدسيات حلبي مراسل العربيه زياد يعني
كيف تلقف الجانب الاسرائيلي اليوم ورقه
المطالب الفلسطينيه هي طبعا ليست بالجديده
ولكن اليوم
بخضام هذا المسار الذي اعاد الامريكيين
التذكير به المسار الدبلوماسي كيف هي ردود
الفعل من هناك
لا عمليا اعاده اعيدت الى الواجهه القضيه
الفلسطينيه وهذا ما يقلق حكومه نتنياهو
اليمين في اسرائيل
سلم الاولويات لبنان كان معاكسا لمعرضته
تل ابيب في واقع الامر ركز كثيرا على
الموضوع الفلسطيني وضروره خفض التصعيد
ووقف المواجهه خالك لاما علانيا ضد التوسع
الاستيطاني ضد همم تغيير الوضع القائم في
المسجد الاقصى
وما الى ذلك الامر الثاني ايضا اوضح
للاسرائيليين بان واشنطن همم تعارض ايضا
الانقلاب الذي تقوم به الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على القضاء في اسرائيل
والموضوع الايراني حل الثالثا من ناحيه
طرحات بلانكن وان كان اولا بالنسبه
لاسرائيل طبعا الورقه لا جديده فيها
اسرائيل تعريفه عن ظهر قلب
يعني غالبا لن ااه تتعاطى كثيرا مع هذا
الموضوع همم ربما في اليوم الاخرين لاحظنا
فقط بان نتنياهو لان بلنكن موجود هنا او
عزل للجيش الاسرائيلي بتجميد العمليات
العسكريه تقريبا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله همم راينا ان عدد الاعتقالات قل
جدا فقط لان الامريكيين موجودين هنا بعد
ان يصل الى واشنطن سترينا الشيء ذاته
هل سيعود التصعيد من جديد وبالتالي لا
مفعيل سياسيه لمقاله هناك
اساسا قلنا منذ اللحظه الاولى بان لا قدره
لبنان
ولاعبين اقليميين في التاثير على ما يحدث
تحديدا هذه المره في التصعيد هذه ليست حرب
على قطاع غزه يتدخل فيها وسطاء وتؤثر فيها
فصائل او سلطه فلسطينيه هذه مواجهه عمليا
بين عمليات فرديه وبين الاسرائيليين
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه جنه بوقف هذه
العمليات عاده تستمر وقتا ايه معيانا ومن
ثم تتراجع هكذا شاهدنا عام 2016 على مدى
عامين تقريبا مثل هذه العمليات المتفرقه
وبعدها عمليا
خفتها وبالتالي الامر غير متعلق بما يقوله
في هذا الامر لكن بدون مشاكل بان التصعيد
الحاصل حاليا بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين ووجود حكومه فيها متطرفون
مثل بنت كبير وصمترج همم يعني ربما اعاده
قلي تركيز على الموضوع الفلسطيني الذي نجح
نتنياهو في تهميشه على مدى سنوات مضت
وبالتالي يعني امام هذه الضغوطات اليمنيه
ما المتوقع للمرحله المقبله وهل يعني
الوساطه المصريه التي كان يعول عليها
الجانب الى امريكا هل ممكن ان تحدث اي فرق
بهذا الموضوع
مره اخرى همم التاثير هو فقط عندما تكون
هناك مواجهه معروفه المعالم واضحه
العناوين بمعنى حرب بين قطاع غزه واسرائيل
يمكن لمصر ان تتدخل همم همم
انتفاضه نوعا ما في الطفل الغربيه يمكن ان
تتدخل ولكن عندما تكون هناك عمليات فرديه
في القدس عمليا لا تاثير لاحد تقريبا على
هذا الموضوع وهذه هي الاشكاليه التي
تواجهها اسرائيل في هذا الامر ولكن بدون
ان شك- بان همم الضغوطات الاقليميه
والامريكيه على اسرائيل تحديدا قد تؤدي
الى ربما تراجع حده العنف قليلا اقله ايضا
فيما يتعلق بموضوع الاسطار غدا كان من
المفترض ان يكون الاختبار الاول في
الاستيطان لحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو على
الحكومه ان ترد على المحكمه العليا بخصوص
تحديد موعد لاخلاء الاحمر التجمع
الفلسطيني الخان الاحمر الذي تعارضه
امريكا بشده عمليا لا ارى حكومه
ان تحدد موعدا بعد ان كان بلينكن هنا بيوم
شكرا لك زياد حلبي مراسل عربيه حدثتنا من
القدس
من جانبه حمل الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه تصعيد في
الفتره الاخيره لعدم التزامها بحل
الدولتين وشدد عباس على ان الوقف الكامل
للاعمال الاسرائيليه الاحاديه الجانب هي
المدخل الاساسي لعوده الافق السياسي
لان ما يحدث هذه الايام
تتحمل مسؤوليته الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بسبب ممارساتها التي تقوض حل الدولتين
وتخالف الاتفاقات الواقعه
وبسبب عدم بذل الجهود الدوليه
لتفتيك الاحتجاز
وانهاء منظومه الاستيطان وعدم الاعتراض
بالدوله الفلسطينيه
تحصولها على عضويتها الشامله في الامم
[موسيقى]
رساله واحده طلبت سبع سجينات سياسيات في
ايران بالضغط على النظام في طهران لمنع
عقوبه الاعدام بحق المتظاهرين واشارنا الى
عمليات اعدام وهميه لانتزاع اعترافات
قصريه واكدنا تعرضهن للتعذيب الجسدي
والنفسي والتهديدات الجنسيه كما اضافت
الرساله ان السياسه التي يتبعها النظام
لترهيب النساء ونزع الاعترافات القصريه هو
الصحابهن الى اماكن تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
واجبارهن على مشاهده
بهدف الترهيب وشددت الرساله على ان هذا
الاسلوب لا يقل عن قسوه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
باربي
على خلفيه اعتقال رجل الدين السني مولوي
مراد زاهي حملات في ايران اعلنت ان اجواء
مدينه زهدان اصبحت امنيه وملتهبه اكثر من
اي وقت مضى وقد تشهد انفجارا كلب بركان
حسب وصف الحمله بدورها علقت وسائل الاعلام
واليه للنظام الايراني التي نشرت ان السبب
اعتقاله هو اتهامات مثل تضليل الراي العام
ومحاوله تشويه سمعه النظام واعتبر موقع
حان وقت قال مولاوي عبد المجيد بانها على
ما على دخول النظام مرحله جديده لاختبار
الشعب البلوشي محذرين من انفجار
الاحتجاجات في بلوشستان مضيفه ان النظام
بهذه الخطوه باتاثر على القمع والترهيب
والقيام اعتقالات واسعه النطاق وطبعا خلق
المزيد من الخنق في المجتمع الامر الذي
وصفه الموقع بانها سياسه تهدف لتهديد
المؤثرين الذين يحظون باحترام المجتمع
الايراني وبالحديث هنا عن المؤثرين وعمليه
الترهيب التي يتعرضون لها في ايران حكم
النظام على كل من المدونه الايرانيه
السياج حقيقي وخطيبها امير محمد احمد
بالسجن عشر سنوات ونصف لكل واحد منهما بعد
نشرهما هذا الفيديو الذي يرقصان فيه بساحه
ازداي بطهران واتهمت محكمه الثوره في
ايران المدونين بتشجيع على الفساد
والدعاره وفقا لايران انترناشونال
يكون
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من لندن دكتور حسين بيرا
المتحدث باسم حزب الشعب البلوشي دكتور
حسين يعني من المعروف ان الشعب البلوشي من
اكثر الشعوب التي قدمت تضحيات في
الاحتجاجات بعد الشعب الكردي هل هي لاسباب
قوميه ام طائفيه
وحقوق كامل افراد الشعب الذين شاركوا في
هذه الثوره التي تركز على المراه والحيه
والكرامه اذا المعركه لا تقتصر على
بلوشستان وان وان
كافه الايراني
من السنه الذين تعرضوا للقمع على مدار
سنوات الاربعه والاربعين الماضي
دكتور حسين يعني ما هو دور رجال الدين في
بلوشستان وايضا كردستان في دعم الاحتجاجات
هل يعني لديهم دور مركز هناك ولهذا هناك
حساسيه بالغه من قبل السلطات المركزيه
تجاههم
رجال الدين
القاده السياسيين وكذلك دينين وبالتالي
فان دورهم ليقتصر على البعد الديني وانما
يشمل ايضا الجانب السياسي اما في كردستان
الوضع مختلف حيث ان الحجاب السياسيه هي
تقوم بدور اكثر نشاطا في الحقل السياسي
والقاده الدينيين ويكافحون ايضا ضد هذا
النظام وبناء عليه نستطيع ان نقول انه حتى
الراهن فان رجال الدين هم الذين قاموا
بالدور الاساسي في الحمله المناهضه لنظام
الايراني
المناطق السنيه في شرق ايران
جنوبها وكذلك في شمالي ايران
وفي وسط ايران على حد سوا السنه في الوقت
الراهن يقومون بدور الريادي في هذه الثوره
ومن بينهم الشعب البلوشي الذي هو
ركز
وان شاء بيئه اللي المقاومه ضد النظام
الايراني وانا متاكد بان هذه المعركه وهذه
الحمله سوف تتواصل دكتور حسان لماذا تم
اعتقال مولى وعبد المجيد وليس مولى عبد
الحميد الزعيم الروحي همم البلوش هناك
والذي حمل
المسؤوليه المباشره بقتل ويعني وترهيب
البلوشيستر
[موسيقى]
دام
ان يتم اعتقال ملاوي عبد الحميد نظر الى
شعبيه التي يحظى بها بين كافه مكونات شعبي
الايراني اليوم نستطيع ان اقول ان 70 او
80% من الشعب الايراني
عبد المجيد فهو اقل شهره لكنه مقرب من
ملاوي عبد الحميد ولذلك فين استراتيجيه
النظام تركز على التعقب مساعد مولاوي عبد
الحميد بشتى السولي حتى
اولئك الذين يساعدينا موناوي عبد الحميد
يتم استبعادهم من السلطه ولكن الايراني
لا مو لوي عبد الحميد
ويستحيل ان يتم اعتقاله واذا ما حاولت
الحكومه القيام بامر من هذا القبيل فان
بلوشستان
واجز وكبرى من ايران سوف تنفجر كالبركان
لانك داعيات سوف لن تكون واضحه المعالم
رجال الدين السنه هناك
لثوره التي بدات والتظاهرات التي بدات تحت
عنوان امراه حياه حريه يعني هذا الدعم همم
يظهر تقدم ابيه مواقف رجال الدين بدعم
الحركات الاحتجاجيه بالداخل الايراني
باختصار ما معنى اليوم
اييه اي مس سيده
[موسيقى]
عبد الحميد وكافه رجال الدين في بلوشستان
يتبنون مواقف تقدميه جدا وهم يتصرفون الان
على غرار كل من يعيش في الان في هذا العصر
عصر التقدم في مجال حقوق الانسان والحقل
التكنولوجيا وشعب بلوشيستان
العصر ويعيش الظروف
اما بالنسبه لرجال الدين الشيعه
فهمم
كلهم
او متورتون في الفساد والاقتصاد
مخرج هو التحكم واحكام التي هم في الوقت
الذي يقوم ملاوي عبد الحميد وشعب
بلوشيستان باثوره من اجل جدي مخرج لايران
وحده في تغيير عبر تغيير هذا النظام
وبالتالي فان
الطرفين يتجذبان
كشفت مجله فرن بوليسيه انه في الوقت الذي
تنظر الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
والمملكه المتحده في ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه برزت اصوات تعارض
التصنيف متحجبه بمجموعه من الاسباب ابرزها
ان الحرس الثوري الايرانيه ضم مجموعات من
المجندين يتم اختيارهم بشكل عشوائي
وبالقوه
الطائره الاوكرانيه
في الولايات المتحده تهديدات بتصفيه
المعارضين الايرانيين في بريطانيا
القتال في سوريا الى جانب النظام
احداثهم اشارت فيها اصابع الاتهام الى
الحرس الثوري الايراني الدعوات تنامات
مطالبه بحظر الحرس الثوري الايراني
واعتباره منظمه ارهابيه لكن اصوات خرجت
تعارض التصنيف بحسب فرن بوليسي متحججه
بمجموعه من الاسباب ابرزها ان الحرس
الثوري الايرانيه يضم مجموعات من المجندين
يتم اختيارهم بشكل عشوائي وبالقوه وان
هؤلاء الى خيار لهم سواء اكمال الخدمه
الاجباريه
بوليسيه
لعرقله تصنيف الحرس الارهابيا رغم ان
اسباب التصنيف واضحه ومقنعه وان هذه الحجه
تستند الى فهم خاطئ لاليه التجنيد
والصياغه التي يستخدمها الحرس الثوري
الايراني مؤكده ان المجندين لفتره مؤقته
يحصلون على بطاقه نهايه الخدمه الاجباريه
على عكس اعضاء الحرس ومن بين 400,000
ايراني يتم طلبهم للخدمه العسكريه في
البلاد هناك فقط 50,000 ينضمون سنويا
للحرس الثوري وهؤلاء يتم تدريبهم على
العمل المليشيوي كما يخضعون للتلقين
العقائدي هم وعائلتهم ايضا
وبحسب فرن بوليسيه فان التلقين
الايديولوجيه ركيزه اساسيه لعمل الحرس حيث
يمثل التطرف اكثر من 50% من التدريب في
الحرس الثوري الايراني اليوم
بلال البوجدين العربي
ذكر بيان وزاره التجاره الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده اضافت سبعه كيانات
ايرانيه الى قائمه الحظر التجاري
الامريكيه بسبب مساهمه تلك الكيانات في
الجهود العسكريه الروسيه عن طريق المساعده
في انتاج الطائرات المسيره
تتابعون في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
تدرس حجب هواوي نهائيا عن الموردين
الامريكيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال مسؤول باكستاني
بمستشفى في بشاور ان عدد القتلى جراء
التفجير الانتحاري الذي وقع في مسجد في
المدينه ارتفع الى 100 وانا معظمه ضحاياهم
من رجال الشرطه حيث يقع المسجد المستهدف
داخل مجمع يستخدم كمقرا للشرطه في مدينه
بيشاور وقالت الشرطه ان المهاجم اجتاز عده
حواجز تحرسها قوات الامن للوصول الى مجمع
المنطقه الحمراء في ما اعلنت وسائل
الاعلام محليه ان عمليات الانقاذ من تحت
[موسيقى]
قانون التقاعد الجديد في فرنسا يبدو انه
لن يخرج الى النور وان خرج ستكون ضريبته
كبيره مع المواجهه والاحتجاجات الواسعه
والرفض الواسع من الموظفين الذين عبروا عن
ذلك باضراب ثان اليوم شارك فيه نحو ثلاثه
ملايين بعموم فرنسا هذا بحسب نقبات اما
بحسب وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه فالعديد
يبلغ نحوهم اليوم
و750,000 وتشهد عده قطاعات في فرنسا
كالنقل العمومي والمدارس وانتاج الكهرباء
والنقل والنصاف النفطيه ووسائل الاعلام
حكوميه اليوم شللا بعد اقرار يوم الثامن
ثامن من التعب الشعبيه ضد مشروع قرار
حكوميه لرفع سن التقاعد من الى اربعه 64
عاما رمضان عن اثنين وستين عاما وتم تشغيل
واحد فقط من كل ثلاثه قطارات في العاليه
السرعه اليوم الثلاثاء وعدد اقل من
القطارات المحليه والاق مع تعطيل
متروباريز بشده وهنا قالت نقابه المعلمين
في المدارس الابتدائيه في فرنسا ان نصف
المعلمين اضربوا عن العمل وبالمثل يضرب
ايضا موظفون وصافي النفطيه والعاملين في
قطاعات اخرى من بينها طبعا محطات البث
الحكوميه التي بثت الموسيقى بدلا من
البرامج الاخباريه وانخفضت امدادات الطاقه
الفرنسيه
4.4% اظن العاملون في المفاعلات النوويه
ومحطات الطاقه الحراريه الى الاضراب ايضا
وفقا لبيانات همم السلطه
[موسيقى]
يذهب الينا من باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه حسيني يعني مع هذا العاجل الذي
ورد الان عن الداخليه الفرنسيه بان
المتظاهرين بلغوا مليونا وربع المليون
بيعمون فرنسا كيف كانت خارطه الاحتجاجات
اليوم
نعم في الواقع الاحتجاجات التوزعت على
باريس اليوم تولوز مارسيليا مونبليا نيس
بوردو نمت ليل ستراسبور شاربور ليموج
وبا طبعا اذكر المدن الرئيسيه لا يمكننا
تعداد كل المدن التي شهدت تظاهرات بالنسبه
للاعداد هناك
واسعه بينما تعلن عنه النقابات وما تعلن
عنه وزاره الداخليه على سبيل المثال الرقم
الذي ذكرته ليال هو تحديدا وزاره الداخليه
اعلنت عنه مليون
و272,000 متظاهر عبر فرنسا ولكن النقابات
اعلنت عن مليونين و800,000 متظاهر عبر
فرنسا بالنسبه للعاصمه وحدها النقابات
تقول ان باريس شهدت النزول النصف مليون
متظاهر الى الشوارع بينما تقول الشرطه
وزاره الداخليه ان عدد الذين تظاهروا في
العاصمه لم يتجاوز السبعه والثمانين الفن
ولافط ايضا ان هذا الخلاف حول الاعداد
انسحب على مدن اخرى مارسيليا مثلا تقول
النقابات ان 200 الف متظاهر نزل الى
شوارعها بينما تقول الشرطه ان 40 الف فقط
نزلوا الى الشوارع هذا الاضراب العام
اليوم والتظاهرات يعني الاحتجاجات شملت
عده قطاعات من النقل العام الى الصحه الى
التعليم الى قطاعات الطاقه خصوصا الغاز
وشركه كهرباء فرنسا
بالجانب الاخر هل ممكن ان تقدم اي تنازلات
الحكومه بالمطالب التي وضعها المتظاهرون
وهل قدمت اي تنازلات اصلا
نعم الحكومه لابدا بالشقه الثانيه من
سؤالك قدمت حتى الان عده تنازلات كما تقول
اولا الرئيس ماكرون كان يطرح ان يرفع سن
التقاعد بدءا من اول سبتمبر المقبل بواقع
اربعه اشهر كل عام ليصل الى 65 عاما عام
2031 تراجعت الحكومه وتراجع الرئيس عن ذلك
فوافقت على ان يصل سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
بحلول العام 2030 على ان يرتفع سن التقاعد
ثلاثه اشهر كل عام وليس اربعه اشهر كما
تراجعت الحكومه فيما يتعلق بدويه داخل
المحدود لحد الادنى للاجور في فرنسا 1300
€ الذين يتقاضون هذا الحد الادنى للاجور
سيكون بامكانهم الحصول على راتب التقاعدي
هو 1,100 يورو وليس 1000 و100 يورو كما
كان مقترحا في السابق وليسوا ملزمين بان
لمده ثلاثه واربعين عاما يحصل على الراتب
التقاعدي الكامل اتحدث هنا عن ذوي الدخل
المحدود الاخرون ملزمون كي يحصل على
الراتب التقاعدي الكامل ان يعمل من الان
فصاعدا
و13:40 عاما بدلا من 41 عاما الحكومه تقول
انه لا مجال تراجع لانه هناك عجزا في
تمويل نظام التقاعد سيبلغ عام 2030 حوالي
20 مليار يورو ولا يمكن سد هذا العجز الا
برفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما حالياا الى 64
عاما للاشاره في ايطاليا سن التقاعد هو 76
عاما في المانيا هو اقل بقليل من 66 عاما
وفي اسبانيا هو 65 عاما ليال شكرا لك يا
حسين قنيبر مراسل العربيه حدثنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
اعلنا وزير الدفاع الامريكي الودي اصلا
انا الولايات المتحده ملتزمه باستخدام
الاسلحه التقليديه والنوويه للردعه
والدفاع في كوريا الجنوبيه فضلا عن قيام
واشنطن وسول بتدريبات نظريه لتعزيز الردع
ضد التهديدات النوويه
بالاسلحه التقليديه والنوويه والولايات
المتحده للدفاع عن كوريا الجنوبيه من
انشطه كوريا الشماليه المتساعده هذا ما
اعلن عنه وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي يزور
سور للمره الثالثه بصفته وزيرا للدفاع
التزامنا بحمايه جمهوريه كوريا
الذي يتضمن استخدام مجموعه كامله من
الوسائل العسكريه الامريكيه بما في ذلك
الاسلحه التقليديه النوويه وكذلك الدفاع
الصاروخي
الوزير الامريكي في مؤتمر المشترك مع
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي اشار الى ان كوريا
الشماليه ارتكبت عام 2022 عدا غير مسبوق
من الاستفزازات موضحا ان امريكا وكوريا
الجنوبيه تدين ما وصفه بالاجراءات الخطيره
التي استقرار الوضع في المنطقه ومؤكدا ان
التدريبات العسكريه المقبله بين البلدين
تهدف لضمان ان يقابل الحلفاء التهديدات
النوويه الكوريه الشماليه
وهو ما تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع كوريا
الجنوبيه كذلك
مؤكدامهما بتعزيز التعاون الثلاثي مع
اليابان ايضا
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل ساشير الى ان الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي اجرى مقابله قبل
قليل مع التلفزيون الايراني ولم يتطرق
ابدا لموضوع التظاهرات لا بل تجاهل
التظاهرات الحاصله داخل ايران وتحدث عن
الغلاء عن الوضع الاقتصادي عن الوضع
السياسي
لايران وغيره من الملفات وطبعا تجاهل
نهائيا موضوع التظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي
بدات منذ اشهر في الداخل الايراني وما
زالت مستمره حتى هذه الساعه
اذا هذه الصور للمقابله التي اجراها رئيسي
الى ملف اخر تدرس اداره بايدن حجب شركات
هواوي الصينيه نهائيا عن جميع الموردين
الامريكيين بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالامن
القومي وفقا وكاله بلومبرج وتهدف الخطوه
الى تشديد ضوابط التصدير التي تستهدف
الشركه وفصلها عن المزودين الذين يمدونها
بالمعالجات والمكونات الاساسيه لمجموعه
الهواتف الذكيه بما في ذلك انتل وكان
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب اضافه هواوي
الى قائمه الكيانات السوداء وقيد مبيعات
الشركات الامريكيه اليها لاربع سنوات
وبعدها اصبح على الموردين الامريكيين
للحصول على تراخيص من الحكومه لبيع اي
منتج الى عملاق الاتصالات
يواجه كل من الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
جوبايدن ورئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
تحقيقات بسبب احتفاظهما بوفائه سريه في
مكاتبهما او منازلهما الخاصه وخلال
التحقيقات الجاريه حاليا في هذا الشان
يتساءل كثيرون عن كيفيه نقل الوثائق
السريه والحساسه للبيت الابيض وكيفيه
التعامل معها بعد ذلك لضمان سريهتها
[موسيقى]
لا لا ليست سريه ان كانت سريه او غير ذلك
كيف يمكن ان ينتهي الامر بتلك الوثائق
الحساسه في غير محليها وكيف يتم التخلص
منها عند كل صباح يتم اعداده ملخص يومي
استخباراتيه لشغل المكتب البيضاوي
المواد الاكثر سريه وحساسيه عاده ما يتم
اعدادها خارج البيت الابيض داخل الوكالات
الاستخباراتيه المتخصصه
باستخدام طابعات الخاصه متصله بنظام
البريد الالكتروني المصنف
يقوم الافراد العاملون هناك بطباعه
المستندات وتجميعها في ملف خاص بمجرد ان
يصبح الملف جاهزا يستلمه الشخص الموكل
اليه ايصاله الى البيت الابيض ثم يتم وضع
الملف في حقيبه مغلقه جيدا فيما يسجل
المسؤولون في المكتب بيانات تلك الوثيقه
المستلمه من استلمها وفي اي وقت غادر
والجهه المرسله اليها الوثيقه بعد
الانتهاء من تلك العمليه واصال الحقيبه من
المفترض ان تتم اعاده تلك الوثيقه الى
مكانها مره اخرى
حيث سيتم تسجيل عودتها وفي معظم الحالات
تحرق تلك المستندات او تتم تلك العمليه
لاحقا
ومع ذلك في بعض الحالات يختار الشخص
المسؤول الاحتفاظ بالوثائق لايام او حتى
اسابيع
عمليه معقده يتم بها نقل الوثائق السريه
وارجاعها ومن ثم التخلص منها الا ان
وثائقي فلتت من قبضه تلك العمليه
الامر الذي اوقع الرئيسيين بيض وترامب في
فخها فخ الوثائق السريه
[موسيقى]
العوده مشاهدينا الى مقابله الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس مع تلفزيون ايراني
رئيس وصف الاحتجاجات بالاضطرابات وحمل
الاحتجاجات مسؤوليه الغلاء الذي تعاني منه
البلاد فن السمع
عايش في المجانين 480 مليار دولار
كنا ندبر الاموال
همم دخول من مداخيل البل وكانت من النفط
هذا العام
لا يوجد تعارض بين الدخل والمصروفات
والصرف همم حتى لا نشعر بالعجل في
الميزانيه
نحن
سوف لن نواجه عايش في الميزانيه وهذا تحت
وهذا الام يحتاج الى اداره الحكومه عليها
ان تدير الوضع حتى لا تعاني من اجل
ميزانيه
همم
تاشيش منظومات همم تطور الوضع
الحكومه
خلال هذه الفتره
لنشهد عدم عيش في الميزانيه وهذا عمل كبير
قمنا به كيف تم ذلك
مثلا رواتب المعلمين والرواتب الاخرى لا
اقول هذا ليس حقهم بل هذا حقا والحكومه
عليها ان تدفع لهم ولكن الحكومه
اذا المشاهدين اكتفي بهذا القدر من مقابله
الرئيس